the Inhumans could be getting rebooted
and could be joining the MCU what's up
everybody it's Warren and this is news
that we've all been waiting to hear for
quite some time now the Inhumans were
quite possibly one of the biggest
disappointments that we got from Marvel
in a very long time the Inhumans were
originally supposed to come in Phase
three and debut in a film however that
did not happen instead they got moved to
a TV show but sadly it only lasted for a
single season and with the exception of
a limited IMAX engagement nothing more
it was really developing and this was
pretty disappointing for many fans
because a lot of fans were really
looking forward to an Inhumans film but
also a lot of people really enjoyed the
Inhumans TV show well now it's my
pleasure to report that the Inhumans
could be rebooted for the MCU going
forward and some of the characters could
be recast I'll break down everything you
need to know in this video including the
possibility of Vin Diesel joining the
MCU as Black Bolt quick reminder I'm
giving away an Xbox one and a ps4
winners choice all you have to do to
enter my giveaway is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero or
villain so over the weekend at the
Dallas fan Days Fan Expo Anson mount who
of course played Black Bolt and the
Inhumans TV show was on a panel where he
addressed the possibility of the
Inhumans getting rebooted with a new set
of actors and as it turns out this
reboot will take place inside of the MCU
if it happens because it will be on
Disney Plus speaking about the Inhumans
reboot at the panel this week in ansan
said people might not know this but in
the sort of Hollywood traits there's
rumored to be a negotiation going on
with Disney Plus to reattempt this and
apparently it's well known that Vin
Diesel has always wanted to play Black
Bolt so there's some kind of
negotiations going on he went on to say
I really want there to be another shot
at the Inhumans and I want it to be
successful because I'd love to watch it
and I think it is the most interesting
little corner of the Marvel Universe and
I think it just has to be done it has to
have the right home the right tone and
the right vision overall so anson mount
just confirmed to us that Disney and
Marvel are attempting to reboot the
Inhumans and are currently in
negotiations with Vin Diesel to play
Black Bolt
it's been rumored for some time that Vin
Diesel could be coming to the MCU to
play Black Bolt but this is the first
official confirmation that
gotten from somebody but it's really
really big news a lot of people have
wanted to Inhumans to come back for some
time now but like Anson said it has to
have the right home it has to have the
right tone and it has to have the right
vision overall well Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios and now the
chief creative officer / Marvel
Entertainment is now in charge of all
Marvel TV shows including all of the
Disney Plus shows and he has done the
MCU so much justice over the past eleven
years starting from Ironman all the way
to Avengers endgame so he certainly has
the right vision and Disney Plus is
certainly the right home so far every
Disney Plus show that has been announced
looks more than amazing and not to
mention that every Marvel show that
comes out for Disney Plus will exist in
the MCU so if the Inhumans get their own
Disney Plus show technically they will
be a part of the MCU and this could
definitely lead them to be introduced
and future MCU movies down the road
which is something that everybody has
won and since an Inhumans film was
announced for phase 3 and although we
may never see an Inhumans solo film we
could see them in their own Disney Plus
show and appear in other films in the
MCU as well and right now it seems like
Vin Diesel could be making his MCU debut
leading the Inhumans as Black Bolt so
let me know how excited you are about
this news are you excited to see the
Inhumans get their own Disney Plus show
and would you be excited to see Vin
Diesel play Black Bolt let me know your
thoughts on this Inhumans reboot for a
Disney Plus show in the comments down
below and again don't forget to
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero or villain so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 and so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU
I'm also starting a giveaway soon on
Instagram and Twitter so be sure to
follow me on there and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof